[MUSIC PLAYING]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Hi, and
welcome to episode number
52 of the weekly Google
Cloud Platform Podcast.
I am Francesc
Campoy and I'm here
with my dear
colleague, Mark Mandel.
Hey, Mark.
MARK MANDEL: Hey Francesc.
How are you doing today?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Very happy.
Surrounded by lots of
really cool people here.
We are in Monta-- we're
not in Mountain View,
we're actually in
Sunnyvale, where
the GDE Summit, the Google
Developer Experts Summit,
is taking place.
MARK MANDEL: it's been
really, really cool.
We're hanging out with all
the Google Developer experts.
They're all excellent people
and it's been very [INAUDIBLE].
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
They're so interesting.
So many cool interviews.
We're going to have a
bunch of short interviews
where they're basically
going to be telling us
about what they do, and
they do really cool stuff.
MARK MANDEL: They do
do really cool stuff
and they do a bunch of
events all around the world.
So it's well worth listening to.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
And then at the end, we'll have
a question of the week that
comes from Slack apparently?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, it comes
from the Slack community
Really cool question
about Datastore.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
It is interesting
because actually,
when I heard the
question I was like,
I'm actually not sure about the
answer, and then I was like,
oh it makes sense.
So that will be at the
end, but before, we're
going to have our cool
thing of the week.
And today is actually
about a blog post.
And it's a really cool blog
post, I really like it.
The title is "How to avoid a
self-inflicted DDoS attack--
CRE life lessons".
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, don't.
Like, self-inflicted
harm is just a bad thing.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
The worst part is
that I've actually done
the things that they say,
do not do this.
I've totally written
code that did this.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
And I think it's one of these
articles where you read it
and you're reading like, oh
yeah that totally makes sense.
But until somebody tells you
to do these things you're like,
uh why would that be a thing?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
So actually, the one
that I wrote was-- it's
actually the first one because
I don't do that-- where it says,
try exponential backup
so if something fails.
So what I did was
actually worse--
MARK MANDEL: Before you go into
that, lets set some context.
So the whole idea
of the blog post--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: The whole
idea of the blog post
is, it's not best practices.
It's the worst practices.
Like what are the things
that if you write-- like that
could create issues, right?
So it's like you
should not just send
requests on a fixed interval
regardless of the service
working or not because
then at the end,
basically what you're
doing is you are adding
more and more and
more services trying
to connect to your back end.
And the back end is not
up, so when it comes up,
you have a huge amount of
traffic waiting for it.
So instead, you should
try exponential backoff.
What I did was even better.
I actually wrote
an App Engine app
that whenever it could fail, it
could send a message to itself.
So yeah, it ended up
being very funny to see
how it all of a sudden--
App Engine scales very well.
So I was able to send messages
to itself saying I failed.
MARK MANDEL: And then
there were more messages
that came back to itself.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It was awful.
Software architecture is fun.
So that is one of the things--
try exponential backoff.
It always hurt--
it always helps.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, I know there
are several really great things
in here about if
you're building,
particularly, mobile
apps with services
as a back end that could go
down because software fails.
So techniques like
exponential back off,
adding a little jitter,
implement retry marking, things
like that-- well worth your
time because it can save you
a lot of time if something
goes horribly, horribly wrong
and you need to get
everything back up again.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
It definitely, definitely
helps avoid outages,
and especially when
an outage happens,
minimize the effects of it.
So yeah, definitely
check it out.
I think it's a great blog post.
I really enjoyed it.
And now, to start with the
main content for today,
we're going to be talking with
Alexis Moussine-Pouchkine, also
known as Alexis MP.
He's going to be telling
us a little bit about who
are the GDEs.
MARK MANDEL: And what they do.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
So we're here now
with someone else from our team.
Not a developer advocate though.
But what are you?
Who are you?
Alexis, could you
tell us a little
bit real quick who you are
and what do you do at Google.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE: Sure.
I'm Alexis Moussine-Pouchkine.
I usually go by
Alexis MP and I look
after a number of communities
that we have-- that
is developer communities.
And one of them is Google
Developer Experts, GDEs,
and specifically, the ones
that are specializing in cloud.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
for the episode today,
we're actually interviewing
a bunch of them.
Could you tell us a little
bit about who are they.
What is a GDE and how
do you become one?
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE: Yes,
that's an excellent question.
So a GDE is somebody that's
passionate, obviously,
about a technology, in our
case Google Cloud Platform.
The program here
is a way for them
to be actually involved in
speaking to product managers
and development teams
providing feedback,
and taking what they
learn and eventually,
when this hits the
market-- and trying
to help us get the word out when
it comes to spreading the news
and speaking publicly,
writing blogs.
So a number of listeners
here will probably
recognize some of the names
as people authoring blogs
and may be good public
speakers as well.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
they're all definitely
very active in
the open community
but I've heard that they also
get privilege access to Google
information.
Like they have an NDA
or something, right?
ALEXIS MOUSSINE
POUCHKINE: Right.
And I'll get to the question
about how you become one,
because that's an
interesting one.
Yes, they're on
the NDA and that is
how we can have some very
interesting conversations
about the things that is
on the product manager's
mind-- like the plans
that they have--
and try to validate those
or amend them, if possible,
and get those people into
early access program,
maybe in a more
systematic way than it
would be if you were completely
outside that program.
And how do you become one?
Well you really need
to be pretty technical.
We're really looking
for people that
are able to pretty much be
developer advocates, right?
We just don't hire them.
We have this relationship
where we share a lot of stuff
under NDA.
We bring them to Mountain
View once a year for Summit.
That's what's happening this
year and this week, in fact.
And we hope that,
in return, we'll
get feedback from them, and
from the sessions today there
definitely is feedback.
Some of it is really
good and I'm really
happy about the way it's going.
And their part of the job is to
help us get the word out there.
So it's very similar to a
number of other programs.
This one needs to
be very technical
and we're looking
for influencers
and we're always looking
for people around the world
to help us spread the news.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, I was
in the room a couple minutes
before, and I was listening
to one of those talks
and I got to say they're
a really tough audience.
When a public manager
is like, well we're
thinking about this and this
and that, rather than be like,
oh that is nice,
someone could be like,
what about this other one?
It's a really tough audience.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE: And
that's what we're looking for.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
They have an opinion.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
They have an opinion
and that's why they are GDEs.
We expect the feedback.
We're not looking for
people that will just rehash
whatever the party line is.
We're looking for people that
make the messaging, whatever
it is, theirs and will
amend it and will give it
their full potential, given
what they got out of it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
That is awesome.
Thank you so much
for taking the time
to tell us about GDEs today.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
You bet.
MARK MANDEL: Now that we have
a great idea of what GDEs are
and what they do, why
don't we go talk to some?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
we're very happy to have
Lynn Langit today.
Hello, how are you doing?
LYNN LANGIT: Hey,
I'm doing great.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And
you're one of the GDEs
that I know the most because
you write a lot about Windows
and so many other crazy things.
Why don't you tell us a
little bit-- what do you do?
LYNN LANGIT: What do I do?
I'm an independent cloud
and big data architect.
Most recently I've been working
as lead on an IoT project
on your competitor's cloud.
But I am actually starting
to do some work now back
on your cloud in a really
interesting vertical,
and that vertical is
scaling cancer genomics.
MARK MANDEL: Can you tell us
a little bit more about that?
LYNN LANGIT: Yeah, for sure.
Well because I'm independent,
I can pretty much
pick my projects.
And so, unfortunately, a
friend of mine got cancer.
And I was startled to
see the lack of access
to personalized treatments.
And so I started to
do some research,
and I have a teenage daughter
who had the good fortune
to attend Stanford this summer
and study cancer biology.
So she had some
information for me as well.
And in looking at the
state of research biology,
I found that there
was an opportunity
to help educate the researchers
about using various vendors'
clouds to scale.
So as I started
to look into this,
I saw that you guys,
here at Google,
actually have a
genomics API in alpha.
And being a GDE, I have access
to some of these alpha things
that you guys have.
So I got access to it and
started working with it
and started learning
biology and here we go.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
That sounds awesome.
MARK MANDEL: That's
really amazing.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So can you share some
of the results of it.
How was your experience?
How is it working
with an alpha project?
LYNN LANGIT: So alpha project--
I mean I build software too,
right?
So alpha projects
are alpha projects.
But the genomics API really
was very much a minimum
viable so it was
variant processing.
So you input the data
and then you magically
get out a variant.
So what the heck is a
variant, for those of us
who don't work in biology?
So I'm still working
on my understanding
so if you are a biologist
listening, don't cringe,
but the idea is that you've got
genomic sequencing input-- so
T, A, G, C, all
that kind of stuff--
and then you compare that
with a reference genome
and then you find the variations
or the variants, which
I'm coming to understand
is actually a very
small percentage, less than 1%.
But it's those variants that
are critical in personalized
medicine.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Interesting.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
Well, I also know you've been
a GDE for a little while.
How did you end
up becoming a GDE?
What got you involved
in the program?
LYNN LANGIT: I did a
presentation on App Engine
about six years ago to an
all Microsoft audience.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, that
gets you the title directly.
MARK MANDEL: That's
points right there.
And I'm curious, what is your
favorite thing about being
part of the GDE program,
what's been great for you?
LYNN LANGIT: So it's
been really cool,
because I've been
since its inception,
to see the program grow.
There were like 10, 15 people
and at this year's summit
there's 300-- around
300 people I think.
And so it's super cool
to see the program grow,
to see new people come
into the community
to get to know people
across the world
because one thing
about this program--
it really is a global program.
And it's really
interesting to me
to learn about different areas
of the world, travel, and work.
Another thing that
I'm doing is I'm
starting to do some
work in the APAC region
and I'm very excited
that you guys are opening
a data center in Australia.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Me too.
LYNN LANGIT: Yeah.
So actually, it's the
combination of the two things--
I applied and got accepted to
speak at a biology conference
on scaling, using Google, how
to scale genomics in Australia.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Congratulations
LYNN LANGIT: I know,
I'm so excited.
So I'm doing that in
February next year.
MARK MANDEL: What's the name of
the conference in case people
want to know?
LYNN LANGIT: It's
called Galaxy 2016.
So Galaxy is an emerging tool
out of the biology research
community.
It was created at Johns Hopkins.
And the idea is
to leverage Docker
so that you can
capture configuration
because another really
interesting problem
in this space is that
a lot of the research
is not reproducible
because people do it
on their desktop-- they
do it on a VM instance,
they don't capture
all the settings--
and so something as simple and
something that we all know,
using Docker to capture
configuration, can really help.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Very,
very interesting.
I never thought
that the cloud would
be so helpful to such
interesting and important
things like cancer.
So thank you so much,
Lynn, for your time
and have fun with the
rest of the summit.
MARK MANDEL: Thanks so
much for being a GDE.
LYNN LANGIT: Thank you so much.
Thanks.
MARK MANDEL: We are joined
again by another fantastic GDE.
Alline, thank you so
much for joining us.
How are you doing today?
ALLINE OLIVEIRA:
I'm doing terrific.
Great.
Really good.
MARK MANDEL: Thank you
so much for being a GDE.
Can you just tell us a little
bit about you and what you do?
ALLINE OLIVEIRA: Sure.
I'm a Java developer and
I worked with App Engine
since App Engine exists.
and I absolutely love
the two because just
make our life incredibly easy
and I hate DevOps and App
Engine just saves my life.
And since then I
never stopped and I'm
glad it's [INAUDIBLE] out
there and working great.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
So are you independent?
Do you work for a company?
ALLINE OLIVEIRA: Yeah, I used
to work with a lot of companies
like Nike, Qualcomm, Citibank.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Heard of them.
ALLINE OLIVEIRA: Yeah, kind
of like that, and you name it.
In Brazil-- I'm
from Brazil-- too,
so a lot of companies in Brazil.
But now, I'm a little bit
tired of corporation work
and I'm playing
with a few startups
and let's see how it goes.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
Whereabouts are you located?
ALLINE OLIVEIRA: I'm
located in Brazil, in Rio.
MARK MANDEL: And so as a GDE,
are there communities out there
that you're involved
with, or events or any fun
stuff about that in
that sort of region
that people should know
about if they want to be
interested in Google Cloud?
ALLINE OLIVEIRA: Of course.
Not specifically for
Cloud-- Google Cloud,
and forget about App
Engine-- but there
are a lot of Google
events out there
and they are growing a lot.
I just went to a DevFest
in central Brazil
and was like 600 developers.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Was
it Belo Horizonte?
ALLINE OLIVEIRA: It was Goiania.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: How many
DevFests do you have in Brazil?
That's cool
ALLINE OLIVEIRA: Yes, we
are big and it's growing.
It's popping up
all over the place.
And that's good because this
is all new things happening.
It wasn't like that before.
So it's been like that now.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
Could you tell us a little bit
about how you became a GDE?
ALLINE OLIVEIRA: Yes, so
a lady that I'm obviously
a fan of-- she's
called Lynn Langit.
She was the first
GDE of the program
and she basically invented it.
Joking.
But she was there
since the beginning
and we are friends
from San Diego.
I used to live in San Diego too.
And we worked together there,
and we play and we teach kids
and we do all fun things
over there we used to do.
And as soon as she became a GDE
and becomes a real programmer
and it starts growing she said,
OK, I have to invite people
and she saw me invite me and I
jumped in right away and said,
what an opportunity.
Right?
What a real recognition.
And that, since then, is making
my life easier for my resume,
for my personal
marketing and everything.
It's incredible
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
we already covered
what was your favorite part of
the platform which is clearly
Java and App Engine, which is
fine it's not Go but whatever.
ALLINE OLIVEIRA: Yeah,
you're right, I got it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: What is your
favorite part of being a GDE?
ALLINE OLIVEIRA: I
think it's two things
that I love the most.
One is the GDE community, that
is just incredible people.
They all look like me.
I feel like totally home.
I feel, outside of the
tech community, the Google
community, or the GDE
community, I feel weird.
Right?
I'm a nerd and I'm weird.
But inside GDE I'm
totally myself.
I'm home.
So I love that.
And outside of being a GDE, for
the whole world, when I say,
oh do you work
for Google though?
That makes me look nice.
I have to rephrase it?
No, I don't.
But still, they don't
care what we say.
They think we are
a Google thing.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah I think
that the name Google opens some
doors sometimes so that's--
ALLINE OLIVEIRA: All the doors.
All doors I want to be open.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
That is awesome.
MARK MANDEL: Wonderful.
Before we finish up, are
there anything coming up
or any events or things that
people would like to-- either
you're involved in or
you want to promote
that are happening
in your region
that people would
be interested in.
ALLINE OLIVEIRA:
Yes, there's still
a few DevFests going on
until the end of the month,
the DevFest month.
So I'm going to a few of them.
I'm going to speak on
App Engine flexible.
Yeah, and how to reduce
cost on the cloud
because cost has
been a big thing.
And after that, I'm going to
really focus on startup things
and--
MARK MANDEL: What are
the names of the DevFests
that you're going to?
ALLINE OLIVEIRA:
DevFest Campinas
is the one I'm going to speak.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
Thank you so much
for joining us today.
We really appreciate
you taking the time.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Thank
you for being a GDE.
ALLINE OLIVEIRA:
Thank you, guys.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So hi,
we're with Daniel Cukier.
Where are you from?
DANIEL CUKIER: I'm from
Brazil-- Sao Paulo, Brazil.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
I was supposed to go there.
MARK MANDEL: You were
supposed to go there
DANIEL CUKIER: You should.
Definitely.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So tell us
a little bit about yourself.
What do you do.
DANIEL CUKIER: So
I run a company,
a start up in Sao Paulo.
It's a music analytics platform.
We use big data and music data
to help music professionals
to expand their audience and to
develop the [INAUDIBLE] space.
MARK MANDEL: What's the
name of the company?
DANIEL CUKIER: It's Playax.
MARK MANDEL: Playax.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
Could you tell us
a little bit more
about how is it
that you are a GDE.
DANIEL CUKIER: So basically,
I use a lot of Cloud.
I have been using
Cloud, generally,
in my whole life
developing software.
And then the start up-- we
needed a lot of computing power
to start the business so it's
a different kind of business
that you need a lot
of computing to start.
So even from scratch
we didn't have
had customers but we needed
a lot of cloud computing
and Google had this
program for start ups.
So we could get some
incentives from Google Cloud
and then we started
to use Google Cloud.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
So what products
are you using currently?
What is the product that
you're using the most
DANIEL CUKIER: The most
we use is Compute Engine.
So we have something around 50
virtual machines running there
but we also use cloud storage
for file storage actually,
and a little bit
of Cloud SQL also.
Not too much.
Yeah, and the
Monitoring Stackdriver
and the whole other thing.
MARK MANDEL: You said you're
in Sao Paulo, and you're a GDE.
Are you involved with any
events or any communities
up there, stuff like that?
DANIEL CUKIER: Yeah I'm
also a technical adviser
of a venture capital
group in Sao Paulo
so I help a lot of companies in
their portfolios to understand
Google technologies.
So we have private
events that I help them
to start with Google Cloud.
Most of them use Amazon
as their platform.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: For now.
DANIEL CUKIER: Yeah, for now.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So why
don't you tell us what is
your favorite thing
about being a GDE ,
a Google Developer Expert.
If you were to choose one.
DANIEL CUKIER: To be
here with you guys.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent decision.
DANIEL CUKIER: And
now the real answer.
So it's cool to have access
to primer information.
So before the products get
launched-- so we can plan
and maybe when we
know before anyone,
we can-- OK, let's wait because
Google will launch something
in the next month or instead of
trying to tackle this problem
and do a lot of work
on that, we can wait.
And so having privilege
information about that is cool.
And also having access
to many other developers,
other experts, it's great
because we can change knowledge
and this is wonderful.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And
one last question--
what is your favorite product
or feature of Google Cloud
Platform?
DANIEL CUKIER: One feature that
I think is very interesting
is the preemptible instances.
So we use a lot.
So we could actually-- and I
wrote a blog post about it--
could decrease our costs
in 40% after moving
part of our infrastructure
to preemptible instances.
And compared to
others, for example,
compared to spot
instances in Amazon,
it's a lot better because you
have all this complex speed
things that you need to do
and preemptible is much more
predictable, so you know
that the service will go down
in the next 24 hours,
so you plan for it
and you already know how much
you're going to pay for that.
So this is great.
MARK MANDEL: All right.
Daniel, thank you so
much for joining us
and thank you so much for
all the work you do as a GDE.
We really appreciate it.
Thank you so much.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So I'm
happy to have Didier Gerard
in the Google Platform Podcast.
How are you doing Didier?
DIDIER GERARD: I'm fine.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Why
don't you tell us
a little bit about yourself?
We kind of know, Didier,
you're from France,
but what do you do?
DIDIER GERARD: So I'm the
VP engineering at SFEIR.
It's a consultancy company.
We are about 300 developers.
I'm doing some cloud stuff
for about eight years
right now-- for now.
And that's it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So could you tell
us a little bit more
about your experience as
a GDE, how long it's been
since you joined the program?
DIDIER GERARD: So I joined
the program in 2012,
so it's a long time ago.
MARK MANDEL: How did
you end up being a GDE?
DIDIER GERARD: So I
started to use the App
Engine as a beta tester.
It was in 2008.
And at first I was
using it for my own.
I built on top of App Engine
I built Android applications.
It was quite a success because
I've got about 1 million
of download of the
applications and I
found it very easy to use
App Engine and quite useful.
So I started to push App
Engine inside my company
and then the story starts.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
What language was this?
DIDIER GERARD: At first,
I was using Python,
then I switched to Java, and
now I'm using Go, mainly.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Cool so next is PHP?
DIDIER GERARD: I'm not sure.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
So why don't you
tell us a little bit
about your experience
with the platform?
What is your favorite products?
DIDIER GERARD: So you ask
me for my favorite products.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yes, or feature.
DIDIER GERARD: I have two.
App Engines-- I love
App Engines because it
helps to build very
scalable applications
and it's very easy to do that.
For example, I have
built applications
for clients who want to
scale from zero to millions
of people in a few minutes, and
App Engine can help to do that.
And maybe the second
one is BigQuery
because, for the
same reason, you
can have queries that
run billions of lines
and you have the result
in a few seconds.
All of that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, I got
to say that one of the times
I went to, I think it
was in Devoxx Paris,
I went to one of your trainings,
one of your BigQuery trainings.
It was pretty
amazing, I got to say.
I know BigQuery and
I was impressed.
MARK MANDEL: Well it sounds like
you hit up a number of events
for doing presentations
and training.
What have been some of
your favorite events
that you've been talking at?
DIDIER GERARD: I don't remember
which ones was the best--
MARK MANDEL: --favorite.
What was most memorable then?
DIDIER GERARD: Yeah.
I love to talk to
Devoxx, for example.
Also to DevFest and to small
events also because of course
it's fun to go to a large
event with hundreds of people,
but sometimes you
have very nice moment
in a small place with maybe only
30 people, like in a Java user
group of our GDG or
something like that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Why
don't you tell us
about what is your favorite
part about being a GDE-- being
a Google Developer Expert?
DIDIER GERARD:
What I love is just
to share what I know
about the platform.
Just simple.
MARK MANDEL: And is that
mainly through training
and presentations or do
you do anything else?
I'm doing mainly
presentation and training.
I have trained about,
in France, about-- I
think I am near 1,000
people in training.
MARK MANDEL: That's
very, very nice.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
that is more than me.
MARK MANDEL: You gotta
lift your game, Francesc.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That
is pretty amazing.
Yeah, I need to get working.
That is awesome.
MARK MANDEL: All right.
Well, thank you so much
for joining us today.
I really appreciate you taking
the time and thanks so much
for being a GDE.
DIDIER GERARD: Thanks.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Thank you.
MARK MANDEL: Hey, Krishnan.
Thank you very much
for joining us today.
How are you doing?
KRISHNAN S. P. T.: I'm doing
good, enjoying the GDE summit
as always.
This has been my third
GDE summit so far.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
Do you want to tell us a little
bit about you, what you do,
your background?
KRISHNAN S. P. T.: OK.
So I came into the GDE
world from, actually,
the GDG world, which is
the Google Developer Group.
I'm founder of the Google
Developer Group in Singapore,
which I did so in
2009 around June.
That was just six months
after the first GDG--
or it was called GTAC at the
time-- that was created by
[INAUDIBLE].
So I was managing the
group until the end
of last year, that is 2015,
and over the span of 5 and 1/2
years, I did 60 events.
And I've given nearly 20 public
talks in Singapore, Brunei,
Taiwan, Malaysia,
I think virtually
over Bangladesh, a little bit,
I believe, in Indonesia as well.
MARK MANDEL: That's a
fairly impressive resume.
I assume that means you're
based out of Singapore?
KRISHNAN S. P. T.:
I moved to the US.
I had an opportunity to work on
Google Cloud Platform product.
I've got some currently
based in Washington DC.
I'm very new to US
so from this January
I'm living in Washington DC.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And on top of
all these impressive activity,
you also wrote a book?
KRISHNAN S. P. T.: Yes,
I did write a book.
Thanks for reminding--
thanks for remembering it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
I remember that.
I reviewed it.
KRISHNAN S. P. T.:
Oh yeah, you did.
Thank you.
So I wrote the first book on
the Google Cloud Platform.
It was called "Building Your
Next Big Thing On Google Cloud
Platform."
That's very, very
passionate to me
because I got so much
support from Google,
like yourself and
also the other product
managers who reviewed each
and every chapter of the book.
And I believe till
today that it's
the only comprehensive
book that has been written.
I'm looking forward to have
some time to actually rewrite
the book, but probably in
a different form, not as
an [INAUDIBLE] book because the
pace at which the Google Cloud
Platform universe
is expanding, there
is no way I can write
one book cover to cover
and it's just going to
be a Bible very soon.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah by the
time you finish the book,
also we have--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
MARK MANDEL:
--everything changes.
It sounds like you've done
a whole bunch of events.
Were there particular events
around the APAC region
that you found were particularly
great, like community events
or conferences or anything
like that, [INAUDIBLE] you
spoke so much around the area?
KRISHNAN S. P. T.: So
primarily, my talking's were
in the GDG meetups in Singapore,
then on the DevFest in Brunei.
Then there was one event--
it was some kind of a cloud
conference in Malaysia,
I forgot the name--
that was having a
multivendors kind of thing
and I presented about the
Google Cloud Platform there.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So you mentioned that
you've been part of the GDE
for at least three years.
This is the third time that
you've come to the summit.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: What is your
favorite part of being a GDE?
KRISHNAN S. P. T.:
OK, my favorite part
is the opportunity to
test new technologies
and to give direct feedback
to the program managers--
product managers.
That's my favorite
part of being a GDE
and that's where we feel
that we are valued so much.
And we are a small
group of people
who are valued by Google
as a company itself
where they're trusting us
with all these upcoming things
and we can give the
feedback, and in many cases
our feedback actually
productized--
get absorbed into the product.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, I really like
that at the end of every
single session, there's a Q&A,
but it is not really a
Q&A. It's just the audience
giving their opinion
about things,
which is pretty awesome.
KRISHNAN S. P. T.: Yeah.
So it's a really open
discussion, even today,
and I enjoyed every
single session
where I guess we didn't even
have a Q&A at the end of it
because we started
interrupting the speaker
and the speaker
was just enjoying--
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
Well Krishnan, thank you
so much for joining us.
Thank you so much
for being a GDE.
We really appreciate
you taking the time.
KRISHNAN S. P. T.: And thank
you for interviewing me.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Thank you.
So now we are joined not
by one GDE, but by two.
We have Albert and Vikram.
Hi, how are you doing?
ALBERT PADIN: Hello.
VIKRAM TIWARI: Hello.
I'm good.
MARK MANDEL: Two GDEs
are better than one.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
And also, I think that
the good story here
is that they actually
know each other.
How do you know each other?
VIKRAM TIWARI: So we actually
met back in GCP Next last year.
And since then, we have been
in touch with each other
and he is in Indonesia
and I've been in India.
ALBERT PADIN: And
I'm from Philippines.
Close, close, Southeast Asia.
MARK MANDEL: You two clearly
really know each other
very well.
VIKRAM TIWARI: So yeah, we've
been in touch with other GDG
communities and other events.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So it's
Google Developer friends.
That is so cool.
ALBERT PADIN: Actually, it
was quite funny how we met.
So we were standing in line
in queue to the Cloud Vision
booth-- [INAUDIBLE] booth.
And then the guy
said next and I was
like, OK who's going
to go first, you or me,
and the guy says,
both of you come over.
And so we posed together and
then we introduced each other.
I actually didn't get his
name, he didn't get my name,
we just sort of had
a picture together.
And then my friend, a Googler
back in the Philippines,
said, oh you're in GCP.
Meet Vikram, you
should meet Vikram.
And then he tagged
him to my profile
and then I looked and I
was like, I met this guy.
And so I started hunting
him around again.
VIKRAM TIWARI: GCP Next
missed connections.
MARK MANDEL: There's a demo
in that that we could build.
That's super cool.
So why don't you both tell us
a little bit about yourselves
and what your backgrounds
are and what you're doing.
ALBERT PADIN: OK, so I'm the
CTO and co-founder of Symph.
We're a branding design, web,
and mobile development company.
So we do work for
companies and governments.
We do a lot of work-- I think
the brands you recognize
were really like the government
in the Philippines's brand.
The World Bank and other
kinds as well, both local
and overseas the Philippines.
So we have a team
of about 40 people.
We do a lot of our work
in Google Cloud Platform,
obviously.
That allows us to really
build products for our clients
quicker without having to
worry about much of the DevOps.
VIKRAM TIWARI: So I'm a full
stack developer at Omni.
We are based out
of San Francisco
and we are building
a marketing--
we're easing the marketing
needs for all the analytics
performance and whether it's
machine learning on that
and using that to help marketers
simplify their decisions
and edit a collection.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And why
don't you tell us a little bit
about, from your
personal experience, what
is your favorite feature
or product of Google Cloud
Platform?
Maybe you go first, Vikram.
VIKRAM TIWARI: So one of the two
[INAUDIBLE] favorite features,
favorite programs--
I really like
the NoOps strategy for Google.
So that involves
on one end we have
App Engine, on the other
hand we have BigQuery.
So both of them, when
working together,
they form like the
best ease of product
uses for me because I don't
have to manage anything.
And being in a startup,
it's is really good for me
because I don't have to
worry about anything,
like nothing on
the database side,
nothing on the scalability
of the web app that we have.
MARK MANDEL: What about you?
ALBERT PADIN: Yeah, I
mean its similar here.
App Engine-- I mean NoOps is
really a big thing for us.
Like if I can press
one button instead
of having to configure
and do 10 buttons,
I would want the one button
that does the same thing.
So I like App Engine very much.
I also like-- I don't
know if it's Google Cloud,
I don't really know what
official [INAUDIBLE]
is but I really like
Firebase real time database.
It just really
works really nicely.
I mean we spend hours,
maybe even days, trying
to replicate the
functionality ourselves
but when you go
Firebase it just works.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I'm not sure
if Firebase is technically part
of Google Cloud Platform but--
MARK MANDEL: It's
part of the family
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
We do love them.
We love them.
We definitely love them.
ALBERT PADIN: I love them too?
[LAUGHTER]
MARK MANDEL: So
you're both GDEs.
Why don't you tell us a little
bit about what you do as a GDE
and what are some of
your favorite things
to do as a GDE is.
ALBERT PADIN: All right.
So I do a lot of talking.
I like talking
more than writing,
so I don't have much blogs
or even online material.
But I do love talks, so
I go around, give talks,
encourage students,
maybe developers
as well on topics
like App Engine,
Firebase, even machine learning.
So we talk about
TensorFlow, we talk
about getting started
in TensorFlow,
and just going into
tutorials and making sure
that people are getting
to know the latest
and they're getting on board
as opposed to just finding out
what's there when
they start working.
So I really have fun doing that
and mostly just really speaking
around the area.
MARK MANDEL: What about you?
VIKRAM TIWARI: So I used to do
a lot of public speaking back
while I was in India,
and since I moved here,
my focus has changed from public
speaking to direct engagements
and writing more blogs and doing
more hands on testing and hands
on development of alpha
products which are already like,
we have access to.
So I do those, I get
feedback back to team,
or I go direct engagements
with other start ups which
are in Bay Area or start ups
which I have connected through
from India and I could do hands
on management and hands on--
MARK MANDEL: Consultancy.
VIKRAM TIWARI: --hands on
consultancy [INAUDIBLE]
MARK MANDEL: So that's
really interesting.
How did you both end
up becoming GDEs?
How did you end up there?
ALBERT PADIN: So I started
on Google App Engine,
or when I would say
Google App Engine
was the only thing Google Cloud.
That was eight years ago, been
programming on that since.
And then I was just basically
talking about it, advocating
for it, having my own
workshops, didn't even
have Google support
back then-- no swags--
and then suddenly, about
three years after I started,
somebody contacted me and
went to speak at a DevFest.
It was the first
DevFest in our area.
I talk about App Engine.
Nobody really knew about App
Engine back then in their area,
aside from that talks.
So I've just continuously
been doing that.
In fact, I didn't even know
about the Experts program
until I was told that I was
nominated to the program
and I wanted to
talk to somebody.
Like, you're going to get an
interview and I'm like, OK.
And so yeah, that was
pretty interesting.
VIKRAM TIWARI: For me, I've
been pretty much involved
with GDG communities
since I was in school.
So I ran a GDG for
two years there,
then I ran a GDG in New
Delhi for two years.
So I've been pretty
much involved
with the GDG community
and GDE in part,
and I've done multiple events
on Google Cloud and scripts
and web app etc.
But I focused myself after
college into more of the cloud
stuff, and since then
I've been getting
more hands on onto cloud and
since I moved here in SF,
it's been even more hands on
and then somebody from the team,
it was actually Ray Sang who
discovered me, who reached out
to me and he said that,
you should apply for this,
and I met Alexis at the GCP
Next, actually, last year.
And since then I've been here.
Actually Mark took my interview.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Oh, nice, really?
That is cool.
MARK MANDEL: So he has to
say nice things about me now.
[LAUGHTER]
No not anymore.
It was accepted.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Cool, well thank
you so much for taking the time
to talk to us today, and thank
you for being GDEs.
ALBERT PADIN: Thank
you for having us.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Great.
That was-- I was going to
say a great conversation.
That was a bunch of
great conversations.
So thanks to all the
GDEs that we interviewed.
Also to the ones that somehow
got cut off of this episode,
otherwise it could
be like three hours.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, there
are so many GDEs here
I could have spent a whole
20 minutes, half an hour,
three hours talking
to about their stuff.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So interesting.
And even the ones that didn't
want to talk to us-- also
very interesting.
Anyway, I think it's time to
go with a question of the week.
And the question
of the week today
comes, as we said at the
beginning, comes from Slack,
and it is about Datastore.
OK, so if I delete
something from Datastore--
so to delete
something you're going
to use the delete operation
that requires a key--
and you're going to say
delete this key, right,
is that strongly consistent
or eventually consistent?
MARK MANDEL: So Francesc,
that's a really great question,
because like are many types of
things in software development,
it depends.
So basically within
Datastore, if you're
interacting with a record,
whether it's delete or get
or put, if you're interacting
with it through it's
unique identifying key,
that is strongly consistent.
So if I put something
in Datastore
and then ask for
it by its key, I
will get it back straight away.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So that
is strongly consistent.
MARK MANDEL: That is
strongly consistent.
However, generally
speaking, we'll
go into this in a second, when
you query for stuff-- so you're
looking for, say, like numerous
records, so every person
who has an age over
23, for example,
that is eventually consistent.
So you have to take
that into account.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That
means that, in our case,
if you have a key, like a
person that is 30 years old,
and you delete it and then
right after you ask for,
give me all the list of the
people that are over 23,
you might get that person
back because it's eventually
consistent.
MARK MANDEL: Exactly.
And you might not because
it's eventually consistent.
Now, there are some
things in there
to make sure it is
strongly consistent.
There is a thing called
ancestor queries.
So you can tie a
record, essentially,
to another record,
a parent record.
And when you do that,
what that means is
when you do a query you, can
then do an ancestor query.
You're basically saying,
give me every person who's
over 23 who is attached
to this parent record.
In that case, it
will be consistent.
The trade off there
though is in write speed.
So when you write
things to Datastore
that are attached
to a single entity,
you can usually do it
around one per second.
So that's a trade off
you have to consider
when designing how
are you going to use
and how are you
going to structure
your data within Datastore.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
I think that that
makes it pretty clear.
And actually what
I'm going to do is,
there's a really,
really good explanation
of all of this in
a Coursera course.
It's called "Building
Scalable Web Applications
with App Engine" and it's
available for Java and Python.
So I'll put a link to that.
They explain very, very
well how all of this works
and why is it the way it's done.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, data
is hugely, hugely powerful
but you definitely need
to know how it works.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: There
are some constraints,
but in exchange you get
crazy scalability, so
definitely worth it.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
Well, Francesc, thank you
again for another episode.
Are you going anywhere, doing
anything, Just For Funcing?
What are you up to?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So I, again,
released a new episode of Just
For Func, so go check it out.
It's YouTube.com/c/JustForFunc
with a C at the end.
And other than that,
what am I doing?
I'm actually enjoying
some holiday,
so I'll be going to
China for some holidays
and then back to have an
offsite with our beautiful team.
MARK MANDEL: Very nice.
Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I'm very
excited about that one.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
I am not going anywhere for
I think the rest of the year.
Cross fingers.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Are you
coming to the offsite?
MARK MANDEL: I am
coming to the off-side.
That is true, actually.
I am coming to the offsite.
And I will be participating
in Thanksgiving
in some way, shape, or form
which will be interesting.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Eating turkey.
Well, thank you again.
And I think that it's been super
long time since we have not
given our listeners the
ways they can contact us.
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
why don't we do it?
MARK MANDEL: I think so how
can they reach us over e-mail?
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Hello@GCPPodcast.com
MARK MANDEL: The website?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: GCPPodcast.com
or cloud.google.com/podcast.
MARK MANDEL: They can
reach us on Reddit.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Reddit.com/r/GCPPodcast.
MARK MANDEL: Google Plus.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: +GCPPodcast.
MARK MANDEL: On Slack.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
On Slack, there is
that channel called Podcast
which is part of the Google
Cloud Platform community.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
And I think the last one I
think I'm missing is on Twitter.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Twitter,
which is GCPPodcast and also,
you're also forgetting the
fact that we're on YouTube.
MARK MANDEL: Oh yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, so there's
a playlist with
all these episodes
and more on the
Google Cloud channel.
So go check it out.
There's a podcast playlist,
so rather than listening to us
on your mobile phone listening
to a podcast application,
you can also just watch it.
There's not much to see.
It's just an image, but
you can listen to us.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, if you're
a YouTube Red subscriber,
you can download it
offline storage and listen
to it that way, too.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That
is a very good idea.
Had not thought about that.
Good ideas, Mark.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
I'm going to open
up another idea
we had another episode
which is, if you want
to come on the podcast,
but just in a little way--
if you want to record a question
and email it in to us, I say,
like as a Drive or a
Dropbox link or anything
like that-- if you gave
us a good question,
we'll definitely put
it on the podcast.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
And we're actually
considering giving prizes
to people that do this.
We still don't know what but--
MARK MANDEL: Mystery prizes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: --they're
eventually consistent prizes.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, I like it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: There you go.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
All right Francesc, thank
you so much for joining me
yet another week.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Thank you, Mark.
And talk to you and
to you all next week.
MARK MANDEL: See you next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]